you're gonna have to let me try to do
this okay hi I am trying oh here we go
so I am trying to so breastfeeding in
public can be a little bit awkward
sometimes difficult there's just huge
stigma towards breastfeeding in public
which is ridiculous this woman got
screamed at by another woman and a Whole
Foods for breastfeeding and I thought
that was really weird because there
isn't a more whole food so yeah I saw
this clothing line the leche libre
dresses on Facebook and I saw that it
went viral I got really excited about
checking it out giving birth is the most
powerful thing a human body can do new
moms really deserve to like own and
celebrate the power of their body and if
they choose to breastfeed they're
continuing on in that power and so I
created let you Libre because I really
want to give women clothing so they can
celebrate and own their power through
fierce functional fashions I want to try
this because it's supposed to make
breastfeeding on the go a little bit
easier I got four kids so I'm always on
the go what I'm hoping for is I'll be
able to wear this and not look like from
and then I can whip out the nip when she
needs it I've been trying really hard to
find cute fun sexy functional clothing
to wear while I'm breastfeeding my child
and oftentimes you know I'm wearing
things like like this it's just like you
know I have a bathing suit underneath
and sometimes I'm a little overexposed
and I would like to have something
that's a little bit more classy I like
hanging out in sweatshirts but nobody
wants to really lift their whole fat
side out when they have to dress a baby
so if this helps a little bit then great
I'm excited okay so I'm gonna go ahead
and open up the package you see what the
dress looks like looks like a sweatshirt
Here I am wearing the let you libre it's
really cute alright here's the full
thing is definitely comfortable
feels a little weird the only thing is
it's very short please put my shoes on I
mean it's cute it's fun so I'm just
right now going to whip it out and feed
the baby now that it's on me let's go to
the restaurant and give it a try
decided to try out upward breastfeeding
at the park figuring out the navel
[Music]
okay let's be honest most of the time we
really can't go out I love my daughter
but I don't like the limitations but I
do like the fact that if I did want to
go out and even though I try to go out
in the past hour and I got all dressed
up to go to a stupid pharmacy and I
can't have a nice dress on my husband
might think oh look she looks kind of
hot maybe I'll make a second baby with
her some ladies are murderous public
breastfeeding understandably so and this
does make things a little bit easier I'm
sweating now
did they tell you that you sweat when
you breastfeed the children screaming
did you know that that they while
they're eating they're not full enough
at the moment that they have the food
going in them all right I love this
dress it's really cute and it's good
with my skin tone it looks nice with
some kind of red lipstick and it looks
nice when the baby's attached to you I
will use this just fall and this winter
I'm liking it well in that marked my
kids go from us a couple more inches at
the bottom this would be a very
functional and super cool and sexy and
fun outfit to wear so that I could go
out look cute and still feed my baby
[Music]